in toronto there's a basketball fan like
no other i breathe drink
everything about the raptors basketball
he's truly my whole life
is around the raptors season deeply for
the last 22 years i've never missed a
game a raptor super fan
my name is nab bhatia and i'm raptors
super fan
if you've watched any raptors games in
the last decade maybe you've noticed the
bearded man sitting courtside
well that's nav and his story starts in
india and takes him right here to canada
fleeing violence nav left and settled in
toronto he worked hard opened a very
successful car dealership when the city
got its own nba franchise the raptors
arrived and i bought my first two
tickets
[Music]
i enjoyed the game i was
sharing the most in the whole arena
[Music]
the team embraced them and being a super
fan has its perks when the legend kobe
bryant came for his last game to toronto
he came to me
and said super fan i want to thank you
what you have done because
you have created a culture of bringing
everybody together through this game of
basketball he also gets to hang with
canadian royalty
i know drake pretty well
but what's most important about nav
super fandom is that he represents the
changing face of basketball fans around
the world basketball has changed my life
tremendously
it has given me
an opportunity
to integrate my community the south
asians
into the mainstream not may be the first
raptor super fan but he wants everyone
on board
i want to see this game taking to the
next level where all the communities
everybody the sikhs the hindus the
muslims everybody coming to the game
[Music]
we want nebraska to be recognized as a
basketball state
within the next few years
south sudanese players are going to
infiltrate the game massively and i want
omaha to be the center of that because
this is where the community is
[Music]
my name is juan deloni i am the founder
and executive director of the omaha
talents academy
we are a vassal program dedicated
towards serving the south sudanese
population
omaha is the largest population of south
sudanese outside of africa
from the moment that i picked up a ball
it was something that i knew i wanted to
do and i wanted to get better at
when i got the chance to become the
player that i was and ending up in a
division one school and realizing that
hey you know i know guys that are just
as good that are just as capable we're
built to play this game you know the
only thing that's really missing is it's
the training
this is where it all started
a few kids wanted to get some basketball
lessons and right here
you know right here on this concrete is
where we would work on our stuff
we started this program in 2012. four
years later these guys are incredible
players i'm probably spending more time
on the phone with high level division
one coaches than i ever had at any point
in my life
egweck has been probably one of the best
players in the state since seventh grade
the community has wrapped his arms
around them and we want to see a great
do well
i started with the omaha talents when i
was in middle school i was gary play of
the year for state of nebraska in 2016.
i just think a lot about basketball and
all the fortune i've had with it
i was born in south sudan and i came
over to the united states when i was
four
we come from
a journey that's really really really
painful
a lot of us were born in refugee camps
it almost felt like the world is not
designed for us
we've been on the run for as long as i
can remember trying to find a home one
country after another
i grew up in the south omaha projects
i came here at nine years old it made us
men it gave us enough challenges by the
time that we're 18 20 years old we're
ready to take on the world
most people look at this thing here you
know and they they see a clothes hanger
this was actually our first basket i
remember being
yay high you know and grabbing the ball
and trying to dunk on each other
basketball has created a really really
really special brotherhood it brings a
lot of joy in my heart to see all these
other sudanese kids just really making
something out of nothing because when we
first came he really didn't have
anything i'm really excited i think omar
should be exciting i think the
basketball world should be really really
excited about what's going to be coming
we can see it very clearly you know it's
just a matter of time when working
[Music]
it was the game that coined a dozen
catchphrases
and made over a billion dollars in
quarters
but i mean jam almost never saw the
light of day
oh my he's on fire
[Music]
this is nba jam game designer mark
termell so we put together a demo a
video tape vhs we sent it to the nba and
said hey we're making this cool game and
they immediately shut it down and said
no we don't want the nba logo in the
arcades so once we got rejected we made
a videotape of nice family entertainment
centers and we sent that back to them
and said look you know this your logo
can be here so they relented and
provided the license
when we put it in the arcade for the
very first time there were no stats that
differentiated the players everybody
assumed that shaq was a bad three-point
shooter or stockton could steal the ball
so we realized pretty quickly that we
had to you know up our game
to match the real world
well if it's just looking at pure
attributes i happen to be the best
player in the game
when you actually put in my secret
character it just shows question marks
for the stats but they're all tens or
nines
take back from the outside
i'm pretty good at nba
to test the claim we had mark hacking to
the machine there we go and turn on
cheat codes all right now we're talking
usually when somebody finds out that
i've made nba jam they say i spent so
much money on that nba jam or you know i
flunked a class in college because of
nba jam
well i look at the game now i wish it
were smoother but it was the technology
at the time
the game still holds up today
[Music]
sam holtz was 12 years old when he won
espn's 2015 march madness bracket
challenge
i had the best bracket out of 11.57
million people
what if we told you this bracketology
prodigy doesn't even watch college
basketball before the tournament i
really don't watch any college
basketball
[Music]
this time last year young sammy was
filling out his winning ncaa tournament
bracket along with millions of other
americans sam what was your strategy for
success
well i just filled out who i think is
going to win was there a science to your
picks no it's just pick whoever you want
to win there's no science just that
simple
maybe sammy's mom has an idea
i think he was lucky
[Music]
all right let's take a closer look at
some of sammy's predictions why pick 11
seed ucla to make the sweet 16. because
i visited their campus and i really
liked their college or seven seed
michigan state to make the final four
thomas other coach
it's italian and i'm kind of italian too
so or wisconsin to upset then undefeated
kentucky it kind of gets boring to watch
the same team
win and win every year and i wanted to
see you do that you must really love
basketball i'm more of a baseball
football guy baseball is my main sport
how is this possible i mean what are the
chances of filling out a perfect bracket
we consulted bracket expert mike
magazine somewhere in one in
some number of quintillions thanks
professor magazine
any advice for the millions of americans
you'll probably beat out again this year
just pick who you think is going to win
and go with your gut remind us why we
should listen to you because i want it
last year
[Music]
there you have it pick the schools
you've visited don't listen to the
experts and don't watch any college
basketball and you too can reach the
promised land just like sammy holtz
[Music]
these days to be an nba champion you're
probably gonna need to be a top three
point shooting team and who better to
talk threes than the nba's all-time
leading three-point shooter ray allen hi
i'm roy allen
yeah we know i already said that
[Music]
our story begins on february 7th 1945
back when all shots were worth a mere
two points
that day the columbia university lions
were taking on the fordham rams in new
york city and the ncaa introduced the
world to the three-point shot
basketball would never be the same again
once the ncaa permanently adopted the
triple in 1986
the three-point shot mitigated the
advantage taller stronger players were
well born with sure they were good small
players but incentivizing shots from
distance level the playing field or
should i say hardwood court
fast forward 70 years and the three
point shot is the shot and ray allen
knows this rey is the most prolific
three-point shooter in nba history
for now what the hell
and ray like all basketball greats is a
student of the game when did the
three-point jacket introduced to
professional basketball it all started
with the american basketball association
better known as the aba
time out
for all you non-basketball fans out
there the ncaa is a national collegiate
athletic association that's college
basketball the aba a pro league was a
sort of anti-mba until emerged with the
nba in 1976.
fall in the aba featured a flashier
version of basketball with a colorful
ball dunks
and of course
the three-point shot
and for that you can thank then-aba
commissioner george miken who wanted to
give the smaller player a chance to
score and open up the defense to make
the game more enjoyable to fans exactly
so the nba adopted it pretty much right
away right it took a while it wasn't
until 1979 when boston celtic chris ford
my first nba coach hit the first
three-point shot in an nba game the
first of over 380 000 threes made in nba
history
we take a break from our regularly
scheduled programming to bring you the
art of the three-point shot by mr walter
ray allen jr the key to three-point shot
is knowing when you are on the floor
before you get the ball nobody likes a
long tube
you need a great knee bend
gather yourself
next you need great lift straight up and
down
and of course to top it all off you need
an immaculate follow through
it's so easy anyone can do it
[Music]
almost anyone come on little buddy you
got this
get in there
yo your game might be horseshoes